here's what would happen if Jupiter and
Mars switched orbits this change would
put the red planet in the uncomfortable
position of having the two biggest
planets in the solar system on either
side of it Mars would experience a
stronger attraction on the side facing
Jupiter compared to the side facing
Saturn this would compress the rocky
planet the gravitational forces could be
strong enough to reactivate the biggest
volcano in the solar system yeah you
could end up seeing lava spewing out of
Olympus Mons 25 kilometers high into
space Earth would be caught between the
Sun and Jupiter and would experience
cataclysmic problems with tidal bulging
so what you once knew is a lovely
habitable home would transition into a
volcanic hell and with Jupiter suddenly
on the opposite side of the asteroid
belt all those millions of rocks would
be pulled in a New Direction toward it
meaning more than a few would crash into
Earth so